Hey, Bevers!
I got us food!
[ Music playing ]
♪♪
[ Cellphone ringing ]
[ Cellphone buzzes ]
Hey!
Bevers:
Abbi, thank God you picked up.
I fell asleep.
I was sunbathing nude
on the roof again.
[ Laughs ]
You -- you were?
Yeah, anyway,
the door locked behind me.
Can you come up
and bring my kimono?
I'm extremely sunburned.
Everywhere.
All right, Bevers, uh, you know,
cover yourself up.
I don't want to see
your sunburned penis.
Open your eyes.
No.
Ilana: It's kosher, dude.
Open 'em up.
All: Surprise!
What?!
Wait.
What, Ilana?
Oh, my God.
Come on. My girl got to have
a proper, royal queen send-off.
[ Laughs ]
And sorry about
the bridge before.
I was very much processing this
all at once.
But then also, I had to leave to
set this up, so --
Well, this is the cutest thing
I have ever seen,
but I have to change.
Yeah, of course.
Of course.
Guys, Abbi and I are gonna
go downstairs!
All right!
♪♪
Abbi and I are back,
you guys!
Hey!
My God.
Trey!
Batter up!
Geez.
-Hi.
-It's so good to see you.
Yeah.
I'm really happy to see you.
Oh.
Oh,
I got you something.
They're free weights.
What?
Thank you so much.
I'll -- I'll try to
put it on my carry-on.
-Cool, yeah.
-All right.
-Ooh, you all right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got --
Okay. I've always said, Abbi
and incremental free weights,
match made in heaven.
-Yeah.
You're really special to me,
Abbi.
too.
Well, then, I guess
it's now or never.
Abbi Gary Anna Abrams,
will you marry me?
Um...oh, Trey.
Two carats.
No.
Right?
Right, yeah, no.
Yeah, no.
[ Laughs weakly ]
-You know.
-You know what?
It was a big swing.
-No, no, no.
I just figured, this is
my last chance, you know, so --
[ Clears throat ]
It's cool.
Maria -- Cut the video, okay?
Delete it.
She said no.
Okay, well,
I should probably go
'cause you said no
to my proposal,
but promise me you'll eat
for your blood type, okay?
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Done.
Here you go.
-Thank you, all right.
-Oh, you want that?
Thank you so much.
All right, beefcake.
-Ow!
-You've had enough time
to show off your rock-hard tits
and your Adonis ass.
It's time to leave and exit,
dawg.
Okay,
I was just saying goodbye.
And I took off work
for this.
You did? That sucks.
You know what else sucks?
When your best friend
moves away,
and everybody's out for
face time for her.
Get out of here!
But maybe we'll be friends.
I don't [Clears throat]
have any left.
♪♪
-Hey!
-Ohh.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Farts ]
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna miss you.
I'm gonna miss you, too,
Linc.
How's Ilana doing?
I haven't talked to her yet.
Um, yeah.
Ilana is, uh --
[ Laughs ] Aww.
You know what?
Ilana's gonna be great.
Yeah, I'ma check it.
Okay.
All right.
See you later.
-I'll catch you.
Enough.
Get out of here.
Go, go!
Are you Abbi's friend?
Hey.
Hi.
Thank you
for inviting me.
Yeah, you're welcome.
You're Abbi's friend, too,
you know?
Yeah.
[ Sighs ]
We're no longer dating, right?
And, uh, we're gonna
keep growing
our real,
yet platonic friendship.
And that means honesty.
-Yeah.
So, um, I'm gonna be honest
with you.
You got to get
the [bleep] out of here.
-What?
-Yeah, it's time to go.
Yeah.
-I heard about grad school.
Jaimé told me.
I wanted to congratulate you.
Yeah, you're a good guy.
We all know it.
You're gonna be
a great thera--
Go, go!
Whoo-hoo!
Party's over, bitch.
You know, I know it's scary,
you know, moving away.
But it's good to
remind ourselves
that there's other places
besides New York City.
Beautiful places.
And New Jersey.
It's gonna be great.
-Yeah.
-'Sup?
-Okay!
-Jesus!
-Well --
-Hi.
Hi.
So, Ilana,
who are all these people?
Um, they're people
from your building.
I just needed to
fill the party out.
-Ah.
-Mm.
Can't wait for brunch
next weekend.
Jersey City
is pretty damn lit.
Mm-hmm.
Yes, it is.
Go now, though.
-What?
-Like, to --
To leave.
To exit and leave.
Good to see ya, Jersey Boy.
Love ya!
I'm sorry.
♪♪
Hi, guys.
Thank you so much for coming.
You can leave.
Come on, go.
Okay.
So the exit is that way.
Get out of here!
Bye!
Yeah. Yeah.
♪ You know
I be up to no good ♪
[ Door slams ]
Okay, I'm almost here.
I'm almost here.
Now we can connect.
Right.
Well, I'm gonna stay
at my own place tonight.
Gonna give you two broads
some privacy.
And I have
a present for you.
You didn't have to
get me anything.
Oh, well, it's just --
So you can store your cheese
in here.
Everyone will know
whose cheese it is,
and they won't be able to
take it from you anymore.
Thank you, Bevers.
Oh.
[ Sobbing ]
Yeah.
I -- I love it.
It's perfect.
And we'll see each other
again.
[ Sobs ]
Yeah.
All right.
Brunch at Felix tomorrow
at 2:00.
And then a movie.
My choice.
Clear your schedule, bitch.
[ Sobs ]
♪♪
Thanks for the party.
My pleasure.